i don't even do i even want to go into
this
i started getting a bunch of emails
yesterday
from um
i guess people from the community
of stephen
kenneth
destiny
bonnell
ii
attacking me because of my opinion about
this trial
now
i don't really think my opinion about
this trial is particularly controversial
um
as i've said before like tell me exactly
which part people are so angry about
um
my view about this trial is as follows
this trial represents
one of the the most disgusting aspects
of american gun and militia culture and
right-wing culture
okay
um
the existence of these militias and what
include adults and children essentially
um
that are out there to protect businesses
pretending to be
members of the military with
vests and guns and helmet-mounted
cameras
it's gross
it's embarrassing it's one of the worst
things about american culture
american gun culture
is disgusting
the idea of a 17 year old
going to wisconsin and getting a rifle
and walking around and saying anyone
need medico
anyone need medico
anyone need medico
all this is it's gross his mom who seems
supportive
do you have any idea first of all i
would never have ended up in this
situation because i was raised in a way
where i at 17 it never would have even
how the hell am i going to be like hey
you know what maybe i'll get a gun and
go to another state
and offer people medico and protect
business like what
it's a failure of american culture it's
a media failure it's a gun regulation
failure it's a parenting failure it's
all of those things okay now
now
first of all people in the chat
talking about whether or not i own
firearms you know nothing about what i
do or don't do
okay and i've said it before i don't
talk about my personal
relationship to firearms or whether i i
i
you don't know what the hell you're
talking about
okay
um
now in terms of the trial
i think that
on the serious charges
it's going to be not guilty and i think
that
because it's completely plausible that
in the moments at which kyle rittenhouse
shot the two deceased individuals
he did fear for his life or
it at least is plausible that he did and
that's all you need for self-defense
you need the jury to believe
that there is at least some doubt as to
whether this was a reckless
killing and if they think it's possible
that he feared for his life and i think
that that is possible
that not guilty is the verdict on those
charges so again to the people from the
stephen kenneth destiny bennell ii
community
who are emailing me and saying i don't
even really know what what is the
tell me exactly what i'm wrong about
um
now in terms of the charges
first degree reckless homicide
use of a dangerous weapon
first degree reckless endangerment of
safety first degree intentional homicide
um attempted first-degree intentional
homicide with gage grosskroys i think
those are all not guilty
i think those are all not guilty okay so
so tell me where you disagree
and then
um
you know endangering safety recklessly
with a dangerous weapon that could be
guilty possession of a dangerous weapon
by a person under 18 absolutely guilty
violation of the curfew definitely
guilty
um endangering i think this is another
endangering safety with a dangerous web
probably guilty based on what i've seen
so far
okay guys so please let's cut the crap
uh you know we want to maintain a great
relationship with the dgg community and
all of the these different things and we
love you guys and i thought but what are
people even emailing me about
and if okay and if the disagreement is a
philosophical one
uh
you're saying you want to live in a
country
where we celebrate i mean listen if if
this guy is found not guilty
on the on the self you know with the
homicides which i think he will be
because i think that the ev i think the
evidence points to there's certainly
it's plot plausible self defense
um this guy's going to be called a hero
by the right this guy's not a hero
nothing heroic here it's a failure of
parenting it's a failure of judgment
it's a failure of culture
there's
there's nothing heroic that this guy did
he might have feared for his life in a
situation he put himself in for a moment
and that will get him off on these
homicide charges
and that may well be what the evidence
shows
okay
elements of bathrooms please proceed
governor obama
all right